Welcome back everyone is Charlie this is
going to be my new Batman video there are a
lot of questions based on the Michael
Keaton news him coming back as Batman
what does this mean for Robert Pattinson
'he's batman the next Justice League
movie what is canon what is not so we'll
break it all down we got some more
details from Warner Brothers according
to some of the trade publications
yesterday so there's a bunch of Easter
eggs it's not quite as complicated as it
sounds if you're new to the channel be
sure to subscribe to get all the videos
will do a new Amazon giveaway all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and let me know which other movies you
want Michael Keaton's Batman to cross
over with that's right he's going to be in
multiple upcoming DC movies I'll talk
about those through the video just
because it's all part of Warner Brothers
plan to have this all make sense
believe it or not they do have a plan
for all this so first thing number 5
Michael Keaton is coming back as Batman
while we also have them launching a
major new Batman trilogy with Robert
Pattinson and Matt Reeves and we have
Ben Affleck's Batman in the upcoming
Justice League Snyder cut future Justice
League crossover movies and then future
Batman spin-off movies with other
characters like a live-action Batman
Beyond movie the future is Batman as far
as the eye can see it's a good time to
be a Batman fan but the big question now
is as which Batman actors are going to
cross over with the other DC characters
and who's going to be in that next Justice
League team so surprisingly Warner
Brothers is actually borrowing from the
DC TV universe strategy in a rare move
to connect everything and make it all
make sense normally it's the TV shows
that copy what the movies are doing but
comic book movies and superhero movies
have evolved to the point where fans
understand weirder concepts and story
twists that the comics have been trading
on for 40 or 50 years and it's all about
the multiverse Marvel is taking its
movies in the MCU in the exact same
direction take a hard left into the
multiverse to keep things fresh and
weird so number 4 according to The Wrap
yesterday Warner Brothers plans are that
Matt Reeves and Robert Pattinson's
Batman trilogy is still meant to be the
future of the Batman character it's
their crown jewel of Batman in the
movies so to speak and to that end
they're giving Matt Reeves pretty much
free rein to reboot the character in the
Creator
for that franchisee any way that he
wants so everything about the look in
the feel of Batman the tone the setting
the context will be very different from
the Zack Snyder driven ben affleck
batman of the Justice League universe in
the DC EU in in order to give him a
fresh start with the new actor and the
new sort of Batman franchise they're
letting that new Batman trilogy exist
off in its own bubble of continuity
separate from Justice League the Snyder
cut however you want to think about that
line of continuity that started with the
Man of Steel movie what a Matt Reeves
previous statements was something like
yes the movie is part of the DC comic
book universe kind of in the sense that
all the characters exist as part of a
single IP brand under DC Comics but in
reality it's not meant to be connected
to other movies they're not going to be
referencing Superman during the Batman
movie next year they're not going to be
referencing the Justice League or
anything like that
they'll just be talking about the Batman
characters inside Gotham City there's
always the opportunity for them to
change their minds about that in the
future but it's not meant to start out
that way and here's where we get to the
multiverse where it all starts to make a
little more sense
number three Michael Keaton is coming
back as Batman in multiple new DC movies
starting with the flash flashpoint movie
they're going to be filming that movie
early next year into bhoot he's also
coming back as the older version of his
Batman from the 1989 Tim Burton Batman
movies so they're canonizing the burton
verse to the larger DC EU multiverse
remember how I said the movies are
taking a page from the DC TV shows
crisis on Infinite Earths did the same
thing last year with almost all the
previous DC movies and TV shows that
have ever existed going all the way back
to the 1966 Adam West Batman series they
even had a cameo scene from Burt Ward as
his version of Robin
at the time for preparation is passed
the crisis is now upon us all most of
you saw at least some of that so you saw
how they executed that they just had
short cameo scenes with a bunch of
different versions of the characters
from different movies and TV shows they
only did a handful in each episode but
you get the idea everything is canon now
because of the multiverse the difference
with a DC EU in the other DC movies is
that it's harder to say that of the
movie side of things until they
literally have a multiverse scene like
that in a DC movie like you can't
necessarily say that Christopher Nolan's
Batman is connected to the DC EU because
of the multiverse until you actually see
someone from the Christopher Nolan
movies interact with someone from the DC
EU movies the flash flashpoint movie
with Michael Keaton's 1989 Batman will
be the first official time they do
something like that but that's them
canonizing the burton verse you can't
necessarily say that every single DC
movie is going to be connected now
inside the DC EU I'm sure there will be
a lot of other funny multiverse
references hopefully john wesley shipp
gets a cameo scene hopefully Kevin
Conroy at some point we'll get a cameo
scene in one of the live-action DC
movies the version of flashpoint that
they're going to be doing for the flash
movie is going to be very different from
the comic book version
Ezra Miller has spent more time talking
about the movie in the context of
broadening the multiverse then talking
about the actual flashpoint comic post
story multiverse stories are very common
for the flash they've been doing the
multiverse with alternate versions of
the characters of the flash TV show for
several years now so even if you haven't
watched that TV show in a while you
totally know what's going on
it should be impossible now it's be
impossible now so number two next big
question the main reason why they're
bringing Michael Keaton back right now
instead of say using Robert Pattinson
Batman in the flash flashpoint movie for
a big crossover is because of what I
said before they want to protect Matt
Reeves from having to overcomplicate his
Batman movie stories with the idea of
the multiverse but DC needs a Batman in
its bigg Justice League crossovers
Batman is just too big of an IP to leave
him out of these big Justice League
movies in the DC EU Ben Affleck has
already said that he's done being Batman
in the new
movies that's the whole reason why he
said he passed the torch to Robert
Pattinson this is the clip of him on
Kimmel talking about it last year you
know I tried to direct a version of it
and worked with a really good
screenwriter but just kind of couldn't
come up with a version that couldn't
crack it and so I thought it was like
you know time to let someone else take a
shot at they got some really good people
as much of a bummer as that is he is
coming back to do additional voiceover
dialogue for the Justice League Snyder
cut but right now that's it and
technically that's not a new movie
that's an old movie the Zack Snyder
never got to finish making and now he's
just finishing it
so as the rap deadline variety all the
other trade publications were saying
yesterday Warner Brothers solution for
having their crossover Batman in the
future DC EU movies is just to do the
older style Batman with Michael Keaton
in a Nick Fury type of role someone to
cameo and crossover in multiple movies
helping tie everything together leading
up to another big team-up Justice League
sequel down the road and because it's
the multiverse just because they're
bringing Keaton back doesn't mean that
they're erasing the previous DC EU
movies those will still be Canon Ben
Affleck's Batman will still be canon but
because Matt Reeves won't be done with
his Batman trilogy for at least seven or
eight years however long it takes them
to make three new Batman movies and
Warner Brothers will probably want to do
their next Justice League movie before
that happens and they don't want to
crossover with Robert Pattinson Batman
franchise during that trilogy Michael
Keaton's Batman from Earth 89 is just
the solution to that problem you need a
Batman in that next Justice League movie
but you don't want to touch Robert
Pattinson while they're finishing that
trilogy pick up the bat phone and offer
Michael Keaton a giant pile of cash to
come back and even though I haven't
mentioned it yet Michael Keaton is
actually doing the exact same thing with
his vulture character in the sinister
six team-up that they're building up to
in the Marvel movies in the Sony
spider-man movies so this isn't the
first time that Michael Keaton has done
this he's actually going to be in the
Morbius movie asses vulture character
from spider-man homecoming next year so
it'll give you a good idea for what it's
going to be like seeing his Batman pop up
in a bunch of different DC movies but
since Warner Brothers is still saying
that Robert Pattinson's Batman is the
main Batman I think that just implies
that when Michael Keaton does show up as
Batman inside other DC
movies though mostly be smaller cameo
scenes when they made the Nick Fury
comparison think about it this way
they've only been three Marvel movies
really where Nick Fury was in most of
the movie most of the time he just shows
up for a couple scenes then goes away
and I'm also kind of expecting that what
Michael Keaton's Batman does show up on
screen with the other DC characters most
of the time he will not be wearing a
Batman costume he'll just look like old
Bruce Wayne from Batman Beyond so number
one obviously live-action Batman Beyond
is the other thing the Internet has been
talking about all these small Michael
Keaton cameo scenes will be totally
awesome to watch in the thought of him
in a new Justice League movie sounds
amazing but I still think that Warner
Brothers ultimate plan is to develop
another new Batman franchise after Matt
Reeves movies with Batman Beyond Sony is
doing the exact same thing now with its
spider-man movies it has the main MCU
spider-man movies with Tom Hall and
Peter Parker but it's also doing the
spider-man into the spider versed movies
with alternate versions of Peter Parker
and other spider-man and it's also doing
the venom movies with Tom Hardy former
Batman movie villain so obviously Warner
Brothers wants to get to the point where
they can capitalize on other Batman
characters in the movies and Batman
Beyond is just one of the biggest most
popular characters that they've never
tried in any of the big live-action
movies it is a totally fresh take on the
character my only hope for that is that
they do wind up doing Batman Beyond in
the movies that they'll let Kevin Conroy
cameo at some point but everyone let me
know in the comments below what do you
want them to do with Michael Keaton's
Batman outside of the flash flashpoint
movie there was a brand new Superman
movie trailer that DC just dropped I'll
do a video for that later tonight so as
long as you have alerts enable for my
channel you shouldn't see that when I
post it also name a giveaway winner when
I post that while you wait for
everything click here for my other brand
new Michael Keaton Batman video and
click here to learn about the new
version of the Joker that they're
supposedly introducing during the new
Batman trilogy thank you so much for
watching everyone stay safe
I'll see you guys tonight!